so the problem with allowing this spark
to happen across here is if this is not
a mechanical switch we can build
switches out of electronic devices as
well but this is what we use transistors
for and a transistor is a rather small
delicate device and so if I go in here
and I somehow caused a huge spike in
voltage to occur very very likely I'm
going to destroy that transistor that's
used in this position right here as an
electronic switch so the way to deal
with this is to provide a place for this
current to go here's this current that's
flowing through this inductor and the
magnetic energy that's stored around
this inductor is going to force that
current to flow even if we open this
switch and in the case here we saw when
we open a mechanical switch it sparks
right across there so the the inductor
winds the inductor current wins in that
case and it can be very damaging to
whatever's in this position down here
the best way to solve this is with a
device called a diode and this is
another semiconductor device it's not a
switch but a diode has a diode has an IV
curve here's V here's I and it looks
like this the the current I'm just going
to sketch this the current is zero when
the voltage on the diode is negative and
it's somewhere around here the the
current goes up like that so when we
have a diode this is the symbol for a
diode like that and that's plus and
minus V and this is the current through
the diode so positive current and
positive voltage is in this part of the
graph over here and when I have a
positive voltage this is about 0.6 volts
something like that could be 0.5 can be
0.7 when you have a a positive voltage
on this then the current starts to flow
freely through this if this voltage goes
negative so that means that this voltage
is higher than this voltage then the
current actually goes pretty much to
zero very very small value so I'm going
to take advantage of this diode device
to help me with this this problem I have
over here with the current and the way
we do that as we do this we hook up a
diode pointing in this direction here
pretty distinctive but anytime you have
a circuit that has an inductor in it so
it's a solenoid or a motor or a relay
this is a way you can protect the
devices driving your your your coil so
let's look at what happens here when we
push this push button down and let it go
again when we started out we had no
current flowing that push button was
open so there's no current going through
here and there's no voltage difference
across here both of these points are at
3 volts and so there's no voltage across
the diode and that's that point right
there no current no voltage so all the
currents are 0 and the voltage across
diode is zero so there's no current
nothing's happening now we push the
button down and a current starts to flow
through the inductor and there's three
volts across the inductor so let's look
at that there's +3 volts here and
there's zero volts down here so there's
3 volts on this side of the diode this
is the side where it doesn't conduct
that 3 volts represents negative 3 volts
across the diode let me mark the diode
voltage on here here's minus plus the
diode and we'll call this V diode so
this is a video of negative 3 so we're
operating over here out at negative 3
volts on the diode and the current
through the diode is zero there's no
current flowing over here all of this
current is going down and going through
the inductor and doing whatever this
inductor is supposed to do okay now we
open the switch now we open the switch
and you recall a minute ago what
happened was this voltage right here
this voltage went big
this went plus big and we had like a
hundred thousand volts or something
that's where it was headed well we're
not gonna let it get there so I'm gonna
take that away so this voltage here as
soon as this switch opens this voltage
right here this is headed up this is
going up hard but we're not going to let
it get very high and that's the job of
this diode so as soon as this voltage
here gets to about 6/10 of a volt higher
than right here so when this voltage
gets to three point six volts what that
means is that the V diode now equals
about 0.6 volts right this is it 3 volts
this is at 3 point 6 volts so
v diode is 0.6 volts and that puts us
about here on the curve and what's going
to happen is this current that we had
here this current that was flowing down
through this inductor is gonna do what
its gonna go this way it's gonna flow
this way through the diode and that's
this portion of the curve right here and
it'll keep going like that look at that
we provided a current path for this
inductor that's not going to destroy
what's down here the highest voltage
this will get to is whatever voltage it
climbs to on this diode curve here which
is going to be between point six and
point say 0.8 volts so the highest this
is going to get is point three point six
to three point eight volts and typically
and typically a transistor down here
will easily withstand this kind of a
voltage on its terminals so this is
called the effect of having this voltage
go way north is called kickback that's
kickback from an inductor this diode is
a protection diode and basically what it
does is it supplies a pathway for that
inductor current when this voltage goes
above the top end of the inductor so
whenever you build something that has an
inductor in it it could be you can build
the circuit that drives a motor or an
actuator or a solenoid or something like
that or part of a robot this is one of
the circuits you want to keep in mind
whenever you have an inductor and you're
gonna switch it on and off you basically
you want to design in a diode like this
to protect your circuit from those
unstoppable inductor currents